restaurant week is back this year the
12-day event will allow
three square to feed those in need and
the culinary community
the culinary community was hit hard by
the pandemic
now they are getting a helping hand and
of course we're talking about
the restaurants themselves bianca
they're actually
getting a helping back some help back
from three square themselves
tell us more about how they're sharing
in the benefit from
restaurant week yeah so sherry so many
people you're probably getting ready for
breakfast right now
but there's so many folks that are still
out of work or in the midst of looking
for work
and you know what looking in their
pantry and grabbing a box of cereal is
not as easy as it
may seem and that's why the folks here
at three square that's why do they're
doing all that they
can to help those who are still
impacting i know
this is maurice johnson who's the
director of operations here we're not
seeing those
long lines like we did about six months
ago but there are still people out there
who
need food there's still a tremendous
need here in southern nevada
unfortunately there's one in six
individuals that don't know where their
next meal is coming from
so that's why we're here along with our
numerous donors
volunteers and retailers trying to fight
that hunger battle here in southern
nevada
you all were working around the clock
feeding people here in the valley
but some folks that were impacted really
badly were the
restaurant industry and the people in
the culinary field so tell us
how you're benefiting them this year
well this year
is totally different from years past and
we're so thankful that
we have the opportunity to actually host
restaurant week but in years past used
to be four to six dollars from each and
every single cover would be donated to
three square so we want to give back we
know it's been an extremely tough year
so now is just a minimum of one dollar
to be donated back to three square
perfect and then also for folks who
don't know how it works how does this
how does it all work when you go into a
participating restaurant you know
there's
there's people who are participating in
this how does it how does it work so
it's over 120 different restaurants that
are participating in restaurant
week this week this year this year and
long story short
every single restaurant has a prefix
menu just for us
so a person can go online to
restaurantweeklv.org
it's very user friendly and
interestingly enough there are some
restaurants that offer a takeout option
you know so we're very thankful for that
so instead of going out and dining
dining in you can actually have that
option in some participating restaurants
to enjoy it at home all right wonderful
so again it's a full circle we're giving
back to the culinary community and those
that were out of work in that community
and also of course
our families in need all across the
valley so we're actually going to speak
with the restaurant owner coming up in
the next hour and they're going to show
us something on their menu and we
may have a bite or two send it back to
you guys in the studio
always we love to share in that bite or
two that you offer us
bianca thanks so much hopefully three
squares getting back on their feet too
because they've been quite busy during
the pandemic helping everybody out